dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly fajir in this series
we talk about research on all kinds of
physics simulations including fluids
collision physics and we have even
ventured into hash simulations if you
look here at this beautiful footage you
may be surprised to know how many moving
parts a researcher has to get right to
get something like this for instance
some of these simulations have to go
down to the level of computing the
physics between individual hair strands
if it is done well like what you see
here from our earlier episode these
simulations will properly show us how
things should move but that's not all
there is also an abundance of research
works out there on how they should look
and even then we are not done because
before that we have to take a step back
and somehow create these digital 3d
models that show us the geometry of
these flamboyant hair stars
approximately 300 episodes ago we talked
about a technique that took a photograph
as an input and created a digital 3d
model that we can use in our simulations
and rendering systems it had a really
cool idea when it initially predicted a
course result and then this result was
matched with the hairstyles found in
public data repositories and the closest
match was presented to us clearly this
often meant that we got something that
was similar to the photograph but often
not exactly the hairstyle we were
seeking and now hold on to your papers
because this work introduces a
learning-based framework that can create
a full reconstruction by itself without
external help and now squeeze that paper
because it works not only for images but
for videos too it works for shorter
hairstyles long hair and even takes into
consideration motion and external forces
as well the heart of the architecture
behind this technique is this pair of
neural networks where the one above
creates the predicted hair geometry for
each frame while the other tries to look
backwards in the data and try to predict
the appropriate motions that should be
present in
Stingley it only needs two consecutive
frames to make these predictions and
adding more information does not seem to
improve its results there is very little
data quite remarkable also note that
there are a lot of moving parts here in
the full paper for instance this motion
is first predicted in 2d and is then
extrapolated to 3d afterwards let's have
a look at this comparison indeed it
seems to produce smoother and more
appealing results than this older
technique but if you look here this
error method seems even better so what
about that well this method had access
to multiple views of the model which is
significantly more information than what
this new technique has that only needs a
simple monocular 2d video from our phone
or from the internet the fact that they
are even comparable is absolutely
amazing if you have a look at the paper
you will see that it even contains a
hair growing component in this
architecture and as you see the progress
in computer graphics research is
absolutely amazing and we are even being
paid for this unreal this episode has
been supported by Linode Linode is the
world's largest independent cloud
computing provider they offer affordable
GPU instances featuring the Quadro r-tx
6000 which is tailor-made for AI
scientific computing and computer
graphics projects exactly the kind of
works you see here in this series if you
feel inspired by these works and you
wish to run your experiments or deploy
your already existing works through a
simple and reliable hosting service make
sure to join over 800,000 other happy
customers and choose Linode to spin up
your own GPU instance and receive a $20
free credit visit linda.com slash papers
or click the link in the description and
use the promo code papers 20 during
signup give it a try today our thanks to
lee node for supporting the series and
helping us make better videos for you
thanks for watching and for your
generous support and I'll see you next
time